よくお待たせしました
質問コーナーええっでも相談に来たからこっちも結構真剣に答えな信者なんてこう
聖なる空間で質問に答えていくますまあ先に謝っておくんですけどしゃべるの質問には
答えられませんよまだ
鍵をしたけ最近のデュエルマスターズについていてもんね
ああディズニーなので
まあやめましょうカードゲームやばいどうしようは3組の子顔かっこいいマジかっこ
いい同署はめっちゃ好きケアー
助けるどうしよう社長さん猫僕は曲でしかない
そうだこれ
おっしゃいましょう誰かを好きになる子もツって変なボスないんでも言って
それが駄目だったためでいいじゃないですかでも次の多いです
たこがもうちょっと真面目にございますね今回ああ
ベチャ意見もあるけど基本的に真面目に行きますハートゲームや皆沿ってよく言えたな
ないか左地球にしこりがあるしこり
これはやばいらは具合や凝固剤 ni 無事イベントが出そうですどうしたらいいです
か
ああ今年コバさんで受験ですそこで質問なんですが先生は aoa をニュースです
ああ
ao ねてく
んですが a 4で大学入ると留学してからたヒナとびしま僕は一般入試を受けたいん
ですが
社長はエアの女に何だと思いますか早く行くある部分
そうだねーよはもう早くからです姉大手受かってから入りパティするか
ちょっに来れば早く査定額池までの時間がてキロそこを上手く利用できるなっ
まだ英語でもイービーカードだかそこで何もしなかったら一般にして受かった奴とは
凄い学力の差が開くと思って
時間は真逆も使えるなぁあれおすすめです
がんばれ oh で1本
これから水が出て困ったどうしますか
体重をしようがないというフィクソ
と駅サービス兄を一人暮らしなんですけど犬を買うか迷っていますどうすればいいです
か
pn を去るクレアーレしかないでしょはいはい
まりもあなんか犬のロボットそうぞそれがも人間ドックせかって
this デリック
てください
一人暮らしで犬育てたんちょっといいんでもかわいそうだと思う
あまりちょっと
どうかなって思いますずっと入れならいいけどね
社長も支え受かってますよ
ありゃまあ
切ってるよね死んでるような貼り方車方向が定時のは中学の仲間となかなか近くあり
ませんどうしたら言った
蔵も卒業かにパーッとそうだねうんまあそれを覚悟で定時に入ったのかもしれないし
まあそんなもんですよ時間はないという卒業しちゃえばね訂増補
立派な高校生終わったせられから休みの人がもらえると思うし
まずい店今回本当にいるかこれでまたあじゃあねー
それはどうもう毎日がつらいです偽りの友達しかいないでどうやったら友達ができます
これはやれ割れ
どうすればいいどうぞ
つまり彼を切っ
あいつかね心開けると半数ができると思います
5割となっちゃうぶっちゃけ入っちゃいましょうなるほどぉぞ
必要になっていらないよ発給も
バーガー一人でいいと思います
社長個人の意見ですがあったらねまあ楽しんでください自分が楽しいと思うことをする
のが一番いいです
ありったけの愛歌ったラブソングを君だけの花ためにしてきました
どうすればいいですかこれでは遅いんじゃ今で見た目ああそれかありったけ泣いたって
ラブソングを君だけ花束にしてきたんだ
で不足ですどうしましょう
寝てください高校になって中学の時がすごく楽しかったと思ってしまいます航空はどう
やって楽しめばいいですか
プレッシャー中学や楽しかったって今言ってるけど絶対大学になったら高校が楽しくっ
熟年過去はねっ楽しく見えちゃうんですっちょっと高校も終わってから楽しかったなっ
て思えると思うんどぅ
いやー大学楽しかったよバダはないかなコミュ障ですどうすればた2節に彼ができます
か
これ僕も実はあんまり
しゃべるの得意じゃないですよいつも喋ってる人となら公平一ずつ読めるけど
ポイント先の偉い人に聞いたんだけどその人とコミュニケーションするときその人の花
を見てれば話せるっていうか中なんか鼻だけ見てたら
表情がわからないから緊張しないらしい花だけ花止めて使い山だから
あの
アジアを見ててもちょっと目を見てんだと思われるすある肌を見て話すのはすごい
効果的らしいです花を見てはずん是非試してみてください
こういう思いが多分号評価をやつし切れてるんですえっ
こんにちはーん
好きな人いるんですけどその人彼氏いるんですよねやっぱり枚目で日だけ雨んだよ
覚えたやつよなこれは難しいの本当に好きだったら全然月って言ってもいいけどもう
その相手が今幸せに見えたら
そもそも幸せを願うのも
一つの愛じゃないでしょうか
今いいこと言ったらダメでしょはずっと最近女子にモテすぎて大変ですどうしたらいい
ですかハーヴェイグリーンさんこんばんは
どうしたら名きゃりーさんみたいに面白くなりますか
友達の一人にすごい太鼓がいますしかもどんどん話す内容がエスカレートしていきます
9日元で突く38棟だったわーとか
一度2時間しか出てないわとかそんな感じのことですとりあえずどう反応すればいい
ですか
ボルタイプで話よああ
なるほどなー持ってるタイプはもう入ってればいいと思いますよ
それかもそのさらに上を行くとかなるほど
矢部俺も30算数よ日間4中度だわーとか起きてる時間の方が1日より長いバーみたい
なるほど27時間起きてたわーとか言ったらもう向こう姉ビビってにょ惹かれると思い
ます
ほとんどっにどうゆう
事を話しをされたらドキッとしたり楽しかったりしますか
気になるのでお願いします
土井話すと寄付する
話かまずさあ一番
グッとくるのはどんなことが好きなのか誰かれたことあーあー
ブラグ的な何かが甲府になるんです好きな人が真面目で話す機会がありませんどうすれ
ばいいでしょう
これはでも難しいヤーム柄すっ好きな人が真面目
非常に良いことだと思う突破かを切り開くしかないと思う
何パクとク子供一回やったことあって
覚えてるぞ本当にそういう何か僕ナンパとかそういう自分がいけるタイプじゃないん
ですけど
の坂道は
本当に好きな人がいた時一回自分から全く関係ないようになるのに声限り入ったんで
男ならそれくらいしていいと思いますよ男が分からないですけれども
好きならガツンと言ってもいいと思います新学期に入ってから友達はみんなしたが話に
入れる
それが起きてだけ入らないんですどうせてファイルで一か教えてください
汁から売られた子と同じクラスになってしまったどうすれば良いでしょうか
これも好きじゃんだ
中学の時それだったからなぁ
まあアンダーズはすごいクラスで肩身狭かっ
なるほど話してみるのもいいと思います勉強が集中できずなぜか youtube を
見てしまいます
たまたまこの動画を見つけたので相談しましたどうすれば良いですかお城や
閉じるのが一番いいよ時間君たらどうですか私ごと時間からこの時間は自分の中のこと
をする
他の時間は勉強するって自分で時間割を作れば居ると思う
頑張ってくださいそのすぎてとビックのことどう思いますかそりゃ俺も知りたいと思う
か
掃除機その好きなんですけど本年正直トミックあいつはなぁ
バッハ遠い来たんじゃほんといい人ですよ
おしゃべりで
ちょっと顔がアレなんですけどそれっほんといい人なんで
ん
信頼してますよ腰を痛めてしまいましたどうすれば良いですか go to
hospital 部活を辞めようか迷っています
部長などで止めにくいんです解決方法ありますか duo いっぱいあるんですが
とにかく後輩がうざいです
弾み社長がドヤ顔するみたい
これは寝る
まあ物をてぇなぁやっぱり凄いよね思い
扱いづらいと思うしやめてなリーが一番ってか怒って言ったら部長だから米約買っ
ちゃうんですねどうしてもこの時期ってことは食べ2年生カパッ3年生だよね多分
そうだねもうスーパーゲットだったら確かにもうすぐ部活が引退とかだったら
ん
頑張ってもいいんじゃないでしょうか最後まで通して持っていたらいいと思います
振り指定
部活は無理してやるもんじゃないってなんや
自分男子校なんですけど2人がほぼ木わけです怖いですどうぞそれは約
これでたらヤバいんじゃぽ音堂っていうこれ目食べればいいんじゃないですかね
ああもう自分も逆にそうそうぞむしろ彫ってあるみたいな情報蘇峰の世界へって感じで
ね
僕は違いますけどねはーはっはっは
弾みシャツを好きな人から返信が来ませんどうしてくれるんですか
やばいこれはやばいには俺に言うなよどうしてくれるんです勝ったら俺みたいな
待ってくださいこれファミマで働き始めて精神安定剤飛ぶことだ
落ちたらいいですかクラー
元コンビニ店員としてあぁそうコンビニも大変なんで兵士安定剤の能田ファミマで働
くっても場合で止めた方が良いと思います僕のチョコがちょこちょこしていますどう
ですか
これからどんな風に生きていけばいいでしょ
核心に迫る質問鉄が目だのまあ好きなように来ていいと思いますよ
親がこうしろっどれだからそうするんじゃなくてそれを自分の選挙と言って親を納得さ
せる的なもうちょっとわかんないですけど
自由に行きましょうねっむーん
怖いよ生んだはいというわけで今回の質問はこれぐらいにさせていただきます
本当にいろんな人の悩みが見ると良かったですなんかコメントに対して誰からその
ポレットでこう返事してるのかとかってああ
どれも僕以外の人でも全然質問は答えてくれると思って
困ったことがあったら近くにいる人に相談してください
僕なんか語の先生みたいになってますけれどもまあねっ
皆さんもあれねー
結局ねーっ
あるですよ俺が最強数
tes
ええええええ
e 7 a